we nearly got a movie that would have
concluded the Stargate Universe story
but more than that we nearly got an sg1
SGA SGU crossover movie this blew my
fragile little mind welcome to sidet
Trek your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel I heard this story a while ago
that there were Plans by Brad r just
after SGU was concluded and the show was
cancelled for MGM to produce this movie
that was going to cross over the crews
of
sg1 sgaa and SGU that they were going as
a team to go and save the crew of the
destiny now I thought it was a myth I
didn't think it was actually true
because they did have a couple of movies
planned I think a lot of people people
who have been around for a while they
know that there were a couple of movies
that didn't get made Joe and Paul's
Stargate Extinction script for Atlantis
and I think it was you and Carl were
working together on Stargate Revolution
is that right yeah that's right and and
the truth is they they not only didn't
get made they they were really
relatively early in their uh in their
development it's not like we were we had
a script that we could have shot we were
still you know we had first drafts I
think and they were something we were
planning to do like six months down the
road Stargate Extinction led by Joseph
MOSI was going to be the movie to
conclude the Stargate Atlantis story arc
Stargate Revolution was going to be a
movie led by Brad Wright and Robert
Cooper that was going to conclude sort
of the sg1 storyline and was apparently
going to focus on General O'Neal really
give Richard Dean Anderson a big
platform to say goodbye to the character
possibly so when I heard rumors about
this cross crossover event I actually
didn't think they were true on the
recent event um that citrek dialate gate
world and three fry short did with a
companion Darren from gate world did ask
Brad about this and he said yeah it's
true basically we had loads and loads of
sets we had all of this setup we had two
major story arcs that had never been
tied off it would almost be stupid
stupid from MGM not to do the movie I
just started typing Darren I I I I asked
uh my uh my boss at MGM who was a huge
Stargate fan and was kind of mortified
by the fact that all this was
happening uh and I said look we have
many millions of dollars worth of sets
here that are going to have to get
packed up and and and and basically
discarded
and if I if I can get a script in your
hands quickly enough I bet I can get the
cast of SGU and and and bring aboard
Enough cast members from the other show
that
uh that I could at least give us a a
two-hour movie to wrap it up or a
90-minute movie to to wrap up
SGU Continuum had made really good money
for MGM the Ark of Truth had made really
good money for MGM
I honestly actually think even though
Brad talks about the DVD sales dropp in
and nobody was buying DVDs I get it but
I actually think if they'd have released
this particularly if they' have done it
in like a fancy metal box or something
and made it a collector's thing that
this would have made money for them as
well and it was it was purely the the
the collapse of the DVD
Market uh that that that triggered the
the uh sidelining of those projects and
and it began as could you just like put
a hold on development for for a couple
weeks as because we're getting some
numbers here that are literally a month
later yeah I think we need to put a like
a like just just a stop on development
on this for for now and just see how it
and then a month later forget it there's
no way we can make these we were
clamoring for more Stargate at this
point SGU had been cancelled and we were
all gutted it's like somebody had run up
and punched Us in the gut Are you
seriously telling me that we wouldn't
have run out and spent 20 quid on this
DVD if they'd have released it or even
better why the hell didn't MGM talk to
Netflix or something like that they'd
have probably paid for it it
absolutely fries my mind that MGM didn't
do this now actually Brad talks about
how he has allies at MGM people that
really were in his corner and that were
trying to get this done it did basically
come down to money MGM was going into a
controlled bankruptcy new owners were
coming in and basically new people just
came in the people that were there that
supported Stargate perhaps weren't just
a few weeks
later it really was an absolute perfect
storm against Stargate like two weeks
into the the process I found out it's
not gonna happen and and uh and even
even as we were going through it it was
could you do it for this number could
you do it for this number and then it
got to the point where
look I'm already I've already taken my
own my own producing fee out of the
budget but I can't help but wonder how
this movie would have worked you know it
started with McKay and you know it began
recognition that Destiny was in trouble
and um and there you
know I I don't want to go into the plot
details but obviously Eli was still
awake and he was desperately trying to
fix the destiny but perhaps he was is
failing perhaps they got communication
through the stones I really didn't like
the constant use of the stones in SGU I
know it was necessary but that was one
area I had a problem with so if they had
to use them again it would be a shame
but to be honest I don't really see any
other the way of doing it but however
they realize back on Earth that the
destiny is in serious trouble and Rodney
sets up a way of trying to dial out to
them which he'd obviously done before
now that could have given us an
opportunity to find out what was going
on with the Atlantis because obviously
the story is going to start with Rodney
McCay Brad Wright talks about how there
would have been some sg1 characters
coming back as well so we could have
found out a little bit more information
about what was going on with them it
would have been an opportunity to maybe
see a retired O'Neil come back huging
his misses General Samantha Carter maybe
or was she a general by then I don't
think she been quite General by then but
you know where I'm going with that it
would have been interesting perhaps that
there was a new enemy or something to do
with the Planet builders that would have
also been a really interesting way of
doing it because I mean the planet
Builders were a race a mysterious race
that really were almost as powerful as
the Ancients themselves maybe even more
powerful so perhaps it's something to do
with them that would have tied all this
together maybe it was the planet
builders that alerted McKay and sg1 to
the problem now that doesn't make sense
the stones makes more sense but either
way it would have been fascinating to
get more information about them it would
have been fascinating to do more though
than just save the crew of the destiny
and it does seem that that's what Brad W
was thinking as well just saving the
crew isn't enough we needed to know why
they were out there in the first place
we need to know that because then it
really just tie off the whole point of
the series without that conclusion
without that reason for them being out
there in the first place what is the
point of the two seasons we got now I
don't know how Brad Wright was going to
do that I think we're going to have to
wait for his Memoirs for him to tell us
like a few other things but it is
fascinating to consider the
possibilities how do you think he might
have done it I'd love to know get in the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com sidre
where most of our new videos appear
first and you get to see them without
the adverts and you even get a free gift
after 3 months for a small contribution
each month that really supports the
channel of course also you can go to
c.co do.uk our dedicated website where
we do articles based on most of our
videos and we try to throw in a few more
details for you to digest so go and
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time